this clip is so funny to me this and not
because of the reason it's funny because
of other reasons when trump said the
thing about
uh how he would be the best women's
basketball coaching nba
just listen this whole thing
and i'll tell you what if i were ever
i'd be the greatest
women's basketball coach in history
because i don't like lebron james i like
michael jordan much better but
but i
mean so dick for no reason but i'd go up
to lebron james it doesn't matter i say
did you ever have any desire to be a
woman
because what i'd love you to do is star
on my team that i'm building up i will
have the greatest team in history
they'll never lose
nobody will come within 70 points of
this team
i mean so
[ __ ] all over the place this thing
i love how all over the place i'll tell
you what if i were ever uh i'd be the
greatest by the way has no idea what
he's saying what he's going to say the
first second dude listen to this
and i'll tell you what if i were ever i
had no idea i'd be the greatest right
here that's what he decided basketball
you know because i don't like lebron
james so dick for no reason dude so dick
for no reason just dragging lebron into
it for no reason
michael jordan much better okay so he
likes markers are much better okay cool
but i'd go up to lebron james it doesn't
matter so drunk dude it doesn't matter
i'd say
ron did you ever have any desire to be a
woman
because what i'd love you to do is star
on my team that i'm building up i will
have the greatest team in history
they'll never lose
nobody i mean dude just said it doesn't
like lebron james and now he's just
[ __ ] basically stroking him off
saying they [ __ ]
be the best player on every team
i don't like lebron i don't know like
you know i would be the best women's
[ __ ] basketball team i wouldn't want
i wouldn't
because i don't like lebron james i'm a
michael jordan guy so i would go up to
lebron james and i'd be like take us to
the championships hey what are you
saying it doesn't matter so drunk dude
when he does that part
basketball coach in history
because i don't like lebron james i like
michael jordan much better but i
but i'd go up to lebron james it doesn't
matter i say lebron why does he say it
it's like breathing it doesn't mean
anything it doesn't matter
so good dude so good it got
so good didn't mean to be that funny but
was
he i go up to lebron james it doesn't
matter i don't like lebron james [ __ ]
lebron james i need him on my team
uh here's his i'm coming oh this is she
got [ __ ] roasted for this roasted and
toasted for this dude she got roasted
good afternoon i want to welcome these
leaders for coming in to have this very
important discussion
about some of the most pressing issues
of our time
i am kamala harris my pronouns are she
and her i'm a woman sitting at the table
wearing a blue suit
and
undermined it
describe too many things after it dude
knows it's [ __ ] described too many
things after it my name is
kamala harris and my pronouns are she
and her i am a woman sitting at the
table
in front of a desk with a lamp behind it
there is a flag on the other side behind
me
the table is glass and i am wearing a
blue suit and have shoulder-length hair
that's violence
dude that's [ __ ] violence to the
trans community dude you can't do that
[ __ ]
just use your pronouns and that's it
just use your also you don't need to we
know you know we know by now hey you're
the [ __ ] vice president we know by
now
here she her
i want to do that
i am crystalia i am sitting here behind
a desk from ikea
and my pronouns are
he she he her what just confused the
[ __ ] out of people
him hi what
[Laughter]
my pronouns are only him never say
anything else even
he or his or anything just him
you can't say
his pants you have to say him pants
caveman talk please thank you very much
now let's get down to the bottom of it
[Laughter]
oh [ __ ] hi i'm krista lee i'm sitting at
a table that we
tried to make fit in this room it's too
it's too small of a room and the table's
too big but that's the studio
my pronouns are corn
porsche
um that's the one joke that everyone
uses for trans people whatever dude i
don't want any violence against trans
people let me just [ __ ] tell people
that i love
i love [ __ ] dude i love them
all
be what you want
think think who you are i don't care man
i don't give a [ __ ] do it have a parade
do bollywood
do it all wow she got roasted and
toasted for that though huh
unreal
[Music]
[Music]